hey youtubers is Charlie so ed sheeran
did a really big interview recently
where he previewed the scene that he's
going to have in Game of Thrones season
seven so I'm gonna play this clip then
I'll explain what he is talking about as
well as the other big cameos that
they've done on Game of Thrones and how
music fits into this series some really
important song something you know
something you may not know but there is
a new round of the game of Thrones
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so here we go here's that
clip have you felt with your bet in the
show now yeah I filmed it in November
ages ago how was that - really fun what
do you doing it what's your what's your
I just do a scene with with Maisie I'm a
I can't really say I don't really know
why I'm allowed to say can you do
anything you many that your lines I sing
a song and then she she goes oh that's a
nice song and I go it's a new one and
then like there's other lines but that's
um great acting like that that's that's
a great acting one starstruck moment
taking a pee next to Harrington
that was before I obviously knew him
obviously being a big game experience
fan yeah being in New York and going
into urinal and kind of looking over and
being like that looks like Jon Snow oh
that is and it's kind of like you don't
expect to see him and you're like
full-on mate with him now I love this
I'm gonna have to answer nothing and
you're like mate to this day you're
right I'd like to say we're friends here
I think you'd say you're friends with it
hope so so yeah it's a little funny
listening to him talk about his early
run-ins with Kit Harington everybody's a
game of Thrones fan all big celebrities
are trying to get cameos on the show so
I'll explain some of the other musical
cameos that the show has had but music
plays a really big role inside Game of
Thrones in the actual exchange that he
says that he has with arias character is
very brief like she's just sitting in a
tavern and she says wow that's a nice
song and he just replies it's something
new so it could be a totally new song
but because pretty much all the songs
with in Game of Thrones are diegetic
like their songs the george RR martin
ritt into the game of thrones story so
when real life musicians cameo in
they're singing songs in Game of Thrones
they're usually playing songs like rains
of castamere song
that exist within the world of A Song of
Ice and Fire so it just sounds like he's
going to be singing a song that we
haven't heard before but that is a game
of Thrones song in what might be
happening is is because they released
this preview of all the characters with
pictures of them all over the place this
picture of Aria inside the tavern might
be her listening to that song so it
sounds like it happens relatively early
in the story because most of the
pictures they've released so far are
from the first couple of episodes so the
last time we saw her she was near the
twins she had just killed Walder Frey so
either she's heading north or she's
heading south so we don't know quite
where she is right here so we could
probably take a wild guess and say that
he's not seeing another version of rains
of castamere because it's been sung
twice on the show the first time or we
should say the most important time that
it was played was at the red wedding
that was Coldplay drummer will champion
the next time we heard someone singing
or playing the rains of castamere was at
the purple wedding when sia Rose played
a really haunting version of that just
meant to mirror the red wedding so
they're just binding those two weddings
together
[Music]
you
good very good off you go
[Music]
and even though all of Santa's weddings
were haunting the one that Tyrion the
one to Ramsay Bolton they did not play
the rains of castamere but weddings on
Game of Thrones are usually a very bad
thing based on some of the alliances
that are being made though do not be
surprised if they played the rains of
castamere again because it is the
Lannister theme so hopefully when Cersei
goes out there's a version of the rains
of castamere playing softly in the
background they didn't sing a song but
all the members of mastodons guest
starred as wildlings during hardhome who
were then killed and raised as whites by
the night king so you have all them
standing here looking really haunting so
even though a lot of guest stars get to
do cool things they tend to not be very
big speaking roles it was Gary Lightbody
from Snow Patrol he was a Bolton soldier
here during season 3 this is the bear in
the maiden fair so it was the big
episode where Jaime rescued Brienne of
Monsters and Men got to be the band that
played with the Braavosi players when
Aria was watching them during season six
they were pretty much reenacting
everything that had happened from Ned
Stark's death all the way through the
purple wedding
[Music]
so what move along give me my chair when
I won't be no more trouble but we are to
deal all Donna dusty I'm stanza thank
you copy rusty so there's always lots of
celebrity cameos probably one of the
best ones was the YouTube comedian Steve
love when the how just comes up in
Visser 8 both of them you really should
add dying you know very brief but very
effective so there are a couple really
cool songs that highlight some of the
big events in Game of Thrones that Ed
Sheeran could be singing that we haven't
heard yet there's the rat cook which is
the infamous legend of a member of the
Nights Watch way back before Aegon's
conquest serving the Lannister King at
the time his son in a pie supposedly the
king's son had done him a slight so as
revenge he cooked him into the pie then
served him to his father the king
because the cook had turned the king
into a cannibal and killed someone who
was under his protection under his roof
that he was then turned into a giant rat
himself and cursed to eat his young
forevermore so the story goes on to say
that he still lives in the Nightfort
there's like this giant white rat that
lives there it is the Rat King the cook
who forced the king at the time to eat
his son so Azaria fed Walder Frey his
sons in a pie she might think it funny
that Ed Sheeran's character sings a song
about another character doing something
very similar but his hardcores re his
characters become it sounds like it's
something that's a little more pleasant
so wolf in the night is a story about
Robb Stark's victory at the Battle of ox
cross they destroyed the Lannister army
now wasn't the battle where they capture
Jaime Lannister but this is all stuff
that happened during season two during
the war of the five kings they captured
Jaime Lannister at the whispering wood
but a wolf in the night is just a story
that celebrates her brother Robb Stark
so she might find that very nice but
there are a lot of other songs that are
sung in the north like the winter maid
or wolves in the hills so unless it's
like a completely new song that has
nothing to do with Game of Thrones which
I'm assuming it's not it's probably
another game of Thrones diegetic song
it's probably one of the other songs
that sung in the north or something that
pays tribute to her family
let me know in the comments what kind of
song do you think he's going to sing to
Aria and which episode do you think it's
going to happen in it just it sounds
like it's going to happen relatively
early in the season and he's not the
only celebrity cameo there's always a
bunch of cameos that make it into Game
of Thrones sometimes the crew like the
director Neil Marshall here worked
himself in to the Battle of Castle black
during the end of season four then you
have Dan and Dave that worked themselves
into the Hall of faces it was even a
George W Bush cameo way back in season
one his head was one of the ones on the
pike but you really had to look to find
it and even David Benioff spirits were
here during the purple wedding so
they're people all over the place
so that's my other big question what's
your favorite cameo so far on Game of
Thrones the really surprising thing is
that George R Martin himself has never
had a physical cameo on Game of Thrones
and he may never will but I think before
season 8 is over they're gonna try and
work him in somehow I mean you just have
to get him in in some way I think he's
just so focused on finishing winds of
winter that he's put that off for so
long because he'd actually have to
physically travel to Europe to do that
it would be hilarious if Jason Momoa
were to come back and cameo is some
unrecognizable person in a background
shot during the war for the dawn there's
going to be so many people on screen
during big scenes like that like big
battle scenes pretty much anyone in
there underneath armor and you wouldn't
recognize them although Momoa does tend
to stick out in a crowd and most
Lannister soldiers are relatively clean
shaven you don't see too many of them
with these giant Mane's of hair like he
wears so leave all your requests for
Game of Thrones bonus videos in the
comments below we're getting closer to
an actual trailer dropping but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Jeremiah Holden please private
message me so I can get your contact
details there was a new round in this
video I'll just announce the winner the
next time I post Game of Thrones so you
can click here for all my promo and
preview videos and you can click here
for brand new Star Wars Episode 7 thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you